as we leave wano and enter the final
Saga we have just about every Straw Hat
getting some kind of significant power
boost and receiving a new Bounty but
with all these new factors in play I
wanted to take another look at the straw
hats and rank them from weakest
strongest before we get into it though
if you're enjoying the one piece content
on this channel and you want to keep it
coming remember to leave a like and
comment down below I think it'd be
pretty fun if you all left your own list
down in the comments right now and then
we see if they line up with mine at the
end of the video and of course make sure
to subscribe to the channel for more
one-piece content in the future and to
keep up with our weekly one-piece
chapter reviews but with all that being
said let's get into the actual video
spoilers and all So currently I think
it's safe to say that there are tiers of
straw hat power levels none of them are
particularly weak but the ones who are
at the top are kind of miles ahead of
the others like I could definitely see
several characters on the straw hat crew
being placed in fights with King queen
or Jack and at least holding their own
but with other characters that just
straight up isn't the case right and
honestly I think a lot of the positions
on this list will be pretty debatable
but I believe that it's probably safe to
say that Chopper is the weakest member
of the crew again I'm not saying Chopper
is weak it isn't like he's kaido minion
number 346 but I also don't think that
he really competes with mid-level Yanko
crew members on average but let's talk
about that in a moment Chopper joined
the crew all the way back in the drum
island arc after Luffy helped him stop
Waffle's Invasion and obviously a
chopper wants to be the Cure All
medicine the best doctor in the world so
his dreams don't particularly align with
him being very strong and because of
that it isn't really a priority and it
doesn't matter too much for his
character which unfortunately means that
he tends to get the least development on
the crew as a lot of One Piece
development is through its fights on
drum Island Chopper's abilities were
fairly straightforward he is a reindeer
who ate the human human fruit this gave
him human-like intellects as well as
three basic forms his normal reindeer
form his tiny hybrid form which is the
most common to be used and his human
form which turns him into something that
looks almost like a Yeti each of these
offers their own unique benefits giving
him better Mobility intellect and
strength respectively however Chopper
also invented the rumble ball the
original Rumble ball would give Chopper
access to four new forms these being the
furry guard point which acted like
Luffy's gum gum balloon antler point
which as you might guess makes his
antlers much bigger and stronger which
is very useful for lifting or tackling
opponents Arm Point which gave him buff
arms for attacking and jump point which
allowed him to jump further and higher
he can also use the scope ability while
he's in his hybrid form which allows him
to find enemies weaknesses but this is
Chopper's biggest weakness the rumble
balls are not perfect this means that he
only has access to most most of his
abilities some of the time the original
Rumble ball only lasted for three
minutes each and needed 6 hours between
uses which is not the ratio you want to
be looking at he could of course eat
more in that time frame but there would
be side effects if he ate a second
Rumble ball he would gain extra
abilities but he would lose control over
his Transformations and begin swapping
randomly if he took a third Rumble ball
he would be forced into monster point a
behemoth-like form where he is filled
with rage and attacks everything and
anyone around him regardless of if their
friend or Foe Chopper especially early
on had a ton of Versatility at his
disposal but was extremely Limited in
terms of time on top of this even
despite his time limitation his
strongest normal form wasn't stronger
than Zorro his fastest form wasn't as
fast as Sanji and his most defensive
form couldn't reflect as much as Luffy's
he's kind of a jack of all trades and
definitely not a master of any however
things would change a bit after he spent
the two-year time skip on Torino Kingdom
Chopper mastered his abilities to the
point where he could access all of his
forms and the new Kung Fu point which
would make the best of both arm and
jumping Point combining them into one
with the exception of monster point this
would be the only form that would still
require a rumble ball to access but
because it only took one Rumble ball
Chopper would remain in total control of
himself although again it would only
last for 3 minutes finally with the help
of Caesar Clown this three minutes was
bumped up to 30 with the trade-off of
leaving him as a shrunken version of
brain point for an unknown amount of
time basically it's similar to the old
effects of Luffy's Gear 3 where he would
shrink after using it obviously
Chopper's monster point is insanely
strong but it is so so limited 30
minutes is getting to the point where
it's reasonable for a fight but I doubt
that more than one fight would really be
resolved in that time on top of that
what happens if Chopper commits to that
30 minute transformation and whoever
he's fighting just runs away for a half
hour and comes back afterwards his
Kryptonite in this form is anyone
slightly faster than him or anyone who
can convince him to have a conversation
yes he has times where he is super
strong but because of the limitations
around his character I think we have to
mark him as the weakest after Chopper
though I think the next three are up for
some debate but for me I would probably
put Brooke here Brooke of course joined
the crew back in Thriller bark where he
immediately stood out as being pretty
strong however he was notably not even a
close match for ryuma with his shadow
even saying himself that ryuma wasn't
taking him seriously at all despite
getting bodied by him meanwhile Zorro
managed to take him out with really no
issue to be fair saying that he doesn't
compare to Zorro is a pretty high bar
especially before the time skip but even
so the Gap is pretty significant that
said Brooke like Zorro is a swordsman
but rather than using three sword style
like sorrow does Brooke instead uses a
cane sword for a more fencing like
battle style emphasizing speed and
precision overpower calling it The
Gentle blade style so yes while Zoro is
a better swordsman than Brooke they're
in different categories so it's not the
easiest thing to compare the Styles
they're both useful in different
situations Brooke of course though is
also the cruise musician and while this
is great for boosting the morale of his
crew it also allows him to have unique
effects on his enemies using Enchanted
Melodies through his music that can
cause people to even fall asleep it puts
him in this kind of interesting position
of being a front-line fighter as he's a
swordsman but also being a support unit
at the same time much like Chopper I
feel like Brooke doesn't have a defined
identity on the battlefield and that
causes him to be a bit lacking overall
now what does help Brooke though is his
devil fruit the yomiyomi Nomi which is
objectively the most fun devil fruit to
say this fruit gave Brooke a second
chance at life after dying in the
Florian triangle however as his soul
took 50 years to find his body he would
be revived as a skeleton this makes
Brooke light enough to run on water and
immune to certain types of damage or
environmental effects for example he's
not able to feel the cold on Punk Hazard
and also is unable to be electrocuted
Brooke also obviously can't be made to
bleed as he's immune to any flesh-based
injury but he is still susceptible to
damage and pain in general the fruit
also grants him a connection to the
underworld this manifests in a few ways
he can Infuse his Blade with the chill
of the underworld which can freeze his
opponents with ice created from his
Soul's energy and of course Brooke can
also astrally project his own soul
allowing him to travel through solid
object sex fly away and spy on his
enemies and finally it allows him to
have some level of sway Over The Souls
of others specifically he mentions how
his music allows him to feel the souls
of others and move them with the melody
most iconically this being used against
big mom's homies as a sort of
pseudo-conquerors hockey that causes
them to stop in place he's basically a
red maid she got fencing he got some ice
powers you got status effects and it all
comes together in this really unique
fighter but like I said with chopper it
seems that the more versatility a
character gets the less they seem to
stand out so because of that I think
Brooke will be our second weakest on to
our third character and I'm gonna be
real this whole section was kind of
difficult to sort out but I think I'm
landing on putting Nami here Nami of
course was officially added to the crew
in arlong park and originally acted more
as a thief or a spy not really meant for
close-up fighting her weapon of choice
at the time was a connectable bow staff
which she used to be able to take down
just about any low-level enemy that they
came across but that's kind of the best
she could do at the time for the most
part there wasn't really anything extra
that she would be doing outside of
navigation spying or theft this changed
a little bit in Alabaster when she was
given the first iteration of the climate
act which was made by usop keeping with
the collectible staff design that she
was used to but now adding the addition
of several party tricks as well as an
occasional actually useful ability these
include the abilities to create heated
or cooled pockets of air which would be
used in tandem with nami's knowledge of
Science and weather to allow her to
create pockets of rain or lightning or
produce mirages or she could just
straight up use the climb attack in
general to entangle and launch enemies
with tornado Tempo the perfect climate
Act improved her abilities with the use
of dials from Sky Pia this modified
version was first introduced on the
straw hats trip to Annie's Lobby on
Rocket Man this kind of solidified the
movement of Nami shifting away from her
role as a thief and more into the role
of something like a mage which is
definitely cool but I do wish she had
more moments that stem from her having
that Thief role in the modern series in
this form all of the gimmicks have been
removed and all of the abilities are
much stronger creating larger and more
deadly lightning bolts as well as more
potent heat and cool balls just in
general anything the old version could
do this is able to do in a stronger form
and her battle with cauliflower was
where she was able to test out most of
these new abilities these sorcery
climate Act was introduced when Nami
returned to sabaori after the time skip
it makes use of all of the technology
and weather knowledge that she gained
studying on with area this ironically
adds in some more casual uses like the
original had but rather than party
tricks these could instead be used for
things like taking a shower or creating
sea clouds in battle is where this thing
really begins to shine though Mirage
Tempo now allows her to turn invisible
gust sword launches a burst of wind at
the opponent she can produce chains of
thunderballs that could be swung almost
like a whip that electrocutes anything
it touches and heat rain snow or thunder
eggs can be produced which hatch for
powerful burst effects and so there is
yet another upgrade as we got the grow
up sorcery climate act which was
improved by usop using pop greens one of
the biggest advantages of this version
is that unlike previous versions it
doesn't need to be carried in separate
parts instead it's just a single piece
which has the ability to grow as the
name suggests the biggest increase to
nami's Power by far through this series
though occurs on whole cake island with
the last upgrade to her Arsenal as Zeus
becomes hers and upgrades all of her
thunder-based attacks then finally in
wano Zeus's Soul would actually fuse
with the climb attack and produce a
sentient weapon he can freely manipulate
the size and shape of the climate act
and even turn it into things like a mace
on top of this Zeus can transfer his
Consciousness into the clouds that Army
creates to create sentient storms that
can Target enemies with homing bolts
honestly at the current point in the
story Nami is devastatingly powerful and
almost unrecognizable from where she
started in terms of indirect combat I'd
say she can pack the biggest punch as
well as do the most AOE damage of anyone
in the crew at this level however when
it comes to hand-to-hand combat she is
also the most at risk having very little
physical strength and durability
basically if she can keep her distance
that's great but if she's ever caught
off guard it's kind of game over that
said I do think her spot is more or less
interchangeable with the next one which
I think should be Usopp picked up in
syrup Village usop is the cruise
Marksman and specializes in ranged
attacks and Ingenuity constantly making
the best of his situation on the
battlefield he was originally a massive
coward but as the series progressed he
has become only a little bit of a coward
which like good for you fam we're making
progress much like Nami his weapon of
choice a slingshot is upgraded several
times through the series his original
Arsenal would focus around a normal
slingshot which would be used to fire
off lead gunpowder eggs smoke bombs fire
pellets Tabasco shurik him and Cactus
bombs for the most part these were kind
of gimmicks or distractions but they
would open up opportunities for Usopp to
put into action some kind of plan or for
the rest of his crew to step in and do
the final blow these were in combination
to his classic close range joke items
like usop Hammer rubber band of Doom and
usopp's spell which I mean they exist
but they're not the most useful and as
funny as they were when they were first
introduced I'm kind of glad they're gone
for the most part they really take away
from this idea of Usopp growing as a
warrior and they made him seem much more
childish usopp's first big upgrade came
at the end of Sky Pia when dials were
incorporated into his Arsenal tone dials
breath dials flavor dials flash dials
and of course impact dials I'll be
became extremely useful we see these
really coming into play with his fight
with Luffy where he manages to hold his
own pretty damn well and controls the
flow of battle for the majority of it
here kind of having the same issue that
I mentioned with nami where when he's at
a distance that's great he's doing
pretty solid for the fight but as soon
as Luffy's able to close that distance
the fight ends pretty quickly after usop
splits from the crew and returns as
sniper King he begins using the dial
powered up giant slingshot Kabuto this
is much stronger than his old slingshot
and is able to fire so far and accurate
that even Marine rifles don't have a
chance in competing with him as we see
in any sloppy the specific reason that
Kabuto is so strong is that it makes use
of breath dials installed that help to
propel his shots however dial stop being
the big thing for Usopp overall after
his time in the Boeing archipelago Usopp
instead begins to integrate pop greens
with his slingshot much like nami's
climate act this allows his slingshot to
grow or Shrink inside eyes while also
gaining extra strength as it grows
however the pop greens aren't just used
in the design of the slingshot they're
actually used as his artillery as well
and with these in his Arsenal he
effectively becomes a long-range
Summoner some of these pop greens that
we've seen include the giant Venus
flytrap powerful seaweed reflexia
flowers bamboo shoots exploding grass
and a giant wolf made of grass there's a
bunch more but basically it allows usop
to have an answer for any situation he
finds himself in it might not always
pack as much of a punch as nami's
Lightning but they're by no means weak
and the options that he offers I think
just Place him a little bit ahead of her
as well as just him being much more
durable in general we've seen Usopp take
some insane hits throughout the series
and that's before even considering that
usop also has access to Observation
hockey which allows him to make shots
that are just ungodly now on to Frankie
we pick him up as we leave water 7 and
obviously Frankie is a cyber after
trying to stop the puffing Tom from
bringing his mentor to any Lobby Frankie
was left broken and brutalized however
he managed to gather scrap metals and
irons on a ship lost at sea and rebuilt
himself the entire front half of his
body was remade with metal and is
effectively impervious to attacks from
the front at least attacks that wouldn't
be able to get through metal his torso
also now opens to store fuel typically
Cola to energize his entire system and
on top of this of course he added a lot
of General modifications and weapons
into himself including detachable fists
machine guns Rockets flamethrowers nail
guns air cannons and extendable calves
that can be used to turn him into a
reverse Centaur his back however remains
more or less untouched as he was unable
to reach it during this process during
the time skip Frankie would spend two
years on the island that vegapunk was
from and learned as much as he could
from his lab he rebuilt his entire body
to become more advanced this new body
being much bigger and bulkier but
housing many more tools and weapons as a
result things like changeable hairstyles
Fireballs tiny hands that extend from
his hands the radical beam nipple lights
and the improved version of all of his
previous abilities he couldn't even turn
his legs into tank treads if he needs to
however despite all of these tools
Frankie is ironically pushed into the
brawler role of the crew often going
against people like Senor pink in
battles of machismo and brute strength
rather than making use of all the
technology he has that said when push
comes to shove his vast array of weapons
does allow him the versatility to find
Solutions in most situations very
similar to usop and it's a trend that
you probably see in most of the
characters we've mentioned so far the
more versatile these characters tend to
be the less specialized and overall
powerful they are as well however a big
benefit that Frankie has though is that
he can make the best of his environment
in order to supplement his own strength
creating structures like stairs or
Bridges is to keep himself in good
positions during a fight or making
on-the-spot weapons to better suit the
situation that he finds himself in in
this way Frankie's potential on the
battlefield is only limited by the
supplies that he has available to him
and while it might not be strong enough
to allow him to defeat people like kaido
or big mom it does allow him to at least
create big opportunities to either
strike back or help his crew escape but
on top of this I think that it would be
unfair to talk about Frankie's power
without also mentioning the Arsenal of
mechs and machines that he supplied the
crew with because Frankie's strength
isn't just limited to what he can do but
also what he allows his crew to do
obviously the sunny is included in this
which allows the straw hats to become a
pretty powerful force at Sea complete
with Cuda burst turrets and the gaon
cannon the gallon Cannon I don't know
how to pronounce that but whatever but
just as important are these shark
submerged 3 which allows for underwater
escape and exploration the black rhino 4
which can Barrel through enemies at high
speeds and even knock over big mom and
the brachio tank 5 which is a tank which
is durable and strong enough to allow
Chopper and usop to deal with big mom
considerably well it isn't like they're
going to win the fight but to say that
the tank helped their odds is an
understatement on top of that the black
rhino and brachio tank can actually be
docked to form the iron pirate General
Frankie this is an extremely durable and
Powerful giant Mech that has machine
guns in the left arm a projectile Shield
his own gaon Cannon rockets and of
course comes complete with a powerful
sword as well much like Chopper's
monster point this is a massive power
boost to Frankie but it just isn't
practical to be used all the time as it
has its own requirements however unlike
monster Point there's no time limit on
this and if the attack fails you won't
be left a Sitting Duck now moving on
from Frankie to what I would consider to
be the last of the mid-tier crew members
being Robin and let's be real Robin is
insanely strong especially early in the
series she joins just after Alabaster
and at this point in the series if the
enemy isn't a logia user or exactly a
character like Luffy or buggy with a
workaround to her abilities Robin could
just snap their neck instantly and take
the win although I guess you do need to
have a neck for her to do this so the
priest she fought on Sky Pia was saved
by a technicality as a child Robin ate
the Hana Hana Nomi a devil fruit which
allowed her body to bloom on any surface
that she chooses and the range is pretty
considerable Robin's go-to attack is to
have her arms Sprout from an opponent's
back have them Reach up to their neck
and clutch it back and honestly there
just isn't much to be done to stop this
we've seen her use this to take out
massive groups of enemies in a single
motion and it's just kind of unfair at
the early stages of the story and much
like Frankie's Ingenuity with his
surroundings Robin's abilities are very
much only limited by Her Imagination in
general when she joins the crew after
Alabaster I would say she could probably
even take on Zoro Sanji in a fight
because there's just not much you can do
against an opponent like Robin although
of course that's just my opinion
obviously if either of them gets a good
hit and they win but getting that
opportunity would be pretty rough I
think what makes Robin so threatening in
general is just that her limbs can grow
anywhere it's pretty straightforward and
simple the range of places that her
attacks can come from as well as the
fact that they can just appear allows
her to become a very talented assassin
but of course she isn't limited to just
creating hands and cracking people's
necks Robin can reproduce any part of
her body eyes spy with ears to eavesdrop
legs to kick with anything she can even
grow a massive collection of hands to
produce wings that will actually allow
her to fly for a few moments and though
it's never seen in the series she could
100 discussed whoever she's fighting by
covering them head to toe in things like
teeth or eyeballs or tonsils or whatever
else and I don't know about you but I'm
not fighting if I'm covered in teeth I'm
gonna be honest I'm gonna go home shower
and question every life choice that
brought me to that moment now Robin's
fruit is not perfect though and there is
a pretty considerable downside that
being that these body parts are a part
of her meaning that they're limited to
her own strength and that if they take
damage she will still feel it but as
Robin becomes more powerful throughout
the series that also means that her
abilities become more powerful for
example during the two-year time skip
Robin learns the basics of Fishman
karate from the revolutionaries and can
Implement those abilities through her
fruit a pretty substantial power boost
Post Time skip Robin also produces
massive versions of her legs and arms
similar to how she used to make wings
but what's even cooler is her ability to
straight up make a clone of herself and
of course in her fight with black Maria
in wano we see her new technique demon
blooming where she creates a giant copy
of her upper body while doubling her
appendages and creating things like bat
wings and fangs and horns
to give off the general appearance of a
demon the Hana fruit allows Robin to be
incredibly creative producing Nets paths
to roll her crew to safety or or even
grabbing Frankie's nuts and bolt on top
of that Robin herself is just incredibly
intelligent great at Espionage and
survival she's a talented assassin and
she's gifted at Deception all tools
which feed into the use of her fruit and
open opportunities for her to be
successful in any fight but with that we
are finally moving on to the monsters of
the crew and like I said every member is
strong but the gaps between those
mentioned so far and those remaining is
just too significant not to bring up now
of these next four characters there's
one that we have the least experience
with and while he has always been shown
to be incredibly powerful I think that
jinbei falls short to both Zorro and
Sanji when you take into consideration
their power-ups from Moana it's
obviously debatable as we haven't seen a
lot of jinbei fighting overall
especially in comparison to the others
but given what we've seen so far I think
this is where I'm putting him we first
heard of Jean Bay all the way back in
the East blue when Johnny and yosuku
mention him we don't actually meet him
until impel down when he shares a cell
with Ace of course Luffy would soon show
up and free Jean Bae and we get our
first look at him in combat when he AIDS
Luffy both in The Escape of impel down
and in the Battle of marineford and at
Marine Ford we see Jean Bay fighting
morya and just dunking on him which is
pretty impressive when he considers that
Luffy and the rest of the straw hats
very recently just struggled quite a bit
to deal with him through the rest of
marineford jinbei would manage to hold
his own against really anyone he came
across and while he wasn't about to
overpower the Admirals he could at least
defend himself against them and protect
others from them for the most part and I
don't know about how you guys saw him
but to me he was always kind of on the
level of Marco or juzo at the time after
the time skip we see him in Fishman
Island and finally he would officially
join the crew all the way in whole cake
Island where he needed to fearlessly
tell off big mom in order to leave her
crew without any restriction from there
he would eventually join up with
everyone in wano where he battled who's
who of the tobiropo and managed to take
the win now something to mention is that
post-wano jinbei is bound to be shot up
to 1.1 billion and I'm sure that a lot
of people are going to make the argument
that he's stronger than Sanji because
Sanji is worth 70 million less however
bounties are not just a representation
of power and you gotta remember that
jinbei is a former warlord he was
instrumental in the founding of the sun
Pirates he has ties to ryugu Kingdom and
he is a former Powerhouse member of big
mom's crew he just has a more developed
resume as well as directly betraying the
world government in his past so in my
opinion at least I think that it makes
sense that he has a higher Bounty
despite being weaker of course jinbei is
far from weak overall though so let's
talk about what he can actually do in
terms of strength and durability jinbei
able to survive attacks like being
punched through by sakazuki which is
more than we can say about some people
and he's strong enough to punch
wadatsumi up into the air which is
pretty impressive considering watsumi's
size where his real strength shines
though is him Fish Man karate jinbei is
a prodigy of fish man karate and even
became a black belt as a child he is
such a master of the craft that his
punches don't need to make contact with
enemies as just the particles of water
in the air surrounding him becomes
strong enough to compress twist and
launch back any enemy around him he can
even manipulate the water in people's
bodies or secrete water from himself
like how hodi did after overdosing on
energy steroids basically when it comes
to Fishman karate and the manipulation
of water jinbei is the expert making him
someone who is just innately powerful
and durable while also being a technical
Master he's kind of like the fish man
karate equivalent of mihawk and then you
have to take into account his Armament
hockey this allowed him to fight Ace for
five days on even footing despite Ace
being logia user and is durable enough
to protect him from Big mom's Cognac and
from who's whose rokushiki abilities and
of course as a fish man all of his
abilities strength and speed are
magnified vastly when he's underwater
James Bay of course also has access to
Observation hockey however it isn't on
the level of people like Luffy or Sanji
now some in a mention with Jean Bae is
that he offers something similar to
usopp's Canon skills or the weapons that
Frankie makes and specifically that is
that jinbei is a masterful Helmsman who
can understand and manipulate the water
around the sunny to allow the crew to
battle Escape or fight regardless of the
situation that they find themselves in
even through massive waves or while
being chased by big mom on top of that
like Chopper he can communicate with
animals on some level although
specifically he can only talk to sea
creatures and this is something that's
pretty interesting as it should only be
merfolk who are able to do that but
despite jinbei being a fish man he's
still capable of it we even see him
summoning massive PODS of whale sharks
now next up is the third strongest straw
hat and I think that's Sanji of course
Sanji joined the crew way back in the
East blue at the end of the brattier arc
and he learned his specialized style of
fighting from zeph this being a method
which focused on the use of his legs
because a chef should never risk
injuring his hands from the start of the
series Sanji has always been both very
durable and very powerful and while
these were not fully awakened at the
time in part this is probably due to his
genetic modifications his father judge
had performed experiments on his
children while his wife was still
pregnant in order to make them super
soldiers sanji's mother however managed
to counteract the effects slightly which
allowed Sanji to keep his Humanity at
the cost of making him weaker than his
siblings these genes would fully awaken
after Sanji wore his raid suit a few
times later in the series and
effectively made him miles stronger than
he had ever been in the past in terms of
his early shows of durability though in
his fight with Caribbean arlong Park
Sanji is is brought down to the depths
of the ocean and then quickly resurface
as a method of crushing his internal
organs through the change in pressure he
took a head-on blast of electricity from
anal and stayed up long enough to thank
him for lighting his cigarette and after
Awakening his german-enhanced genes he
managed to shatter Queen's sword with
his neck without taking any damage Sanji
now has a full-on exoskeleton that makes
him nearly invulnerable to damage and
boosts his healing as well if he does
take damage for example during his fight
with Queen he broke every bone that he
had only to get back up and snap himself
back into place the way I look at it is
that Zorro has always been able to
endure the most damage while Sanji has
always been able to take the biggest
individual hits one specializes in
endurance and the other in durability
now Sanji is also exceptionally fast but
again his genetic modifications bring
this to the next level as he could move
so quickly that Queen mistook him for
being invisible this can be coupled with
Skywalk or blue walk which allow allow
him to more or less move freely through
air or water making him extremely mobile
as well so what we have now is a guy who
moves so fast he can become invisible
with the ability to freely move in any
direction in any environment and in the
event that you actually do manage to
land a hit on him he'll barely take
damage or just shrug it off but at the
same time he has enough power in his
kicks to take down some of the most
powerful pirates in the world Post Time
skip Sanji is able to take down
pacifistas in one shot despite them
being made of things harder than steel
he has added an Armament hockey to be
able to protect against judge's spear or
to damage Luffy pretty considerably and
when he finally adds in his enhancements
he manages to take Queen down in a
single barrage of kicks that sent Queen
flying out of oneigashima and even
reverted him back to his human form
Sanji is incomparably stronger than he
was prior to that battle now and I know
that a lot of people think jinbei is
stronger but I don't really see that as
a possibility after this change it's
kind of hard to talk about what specific
abilities or attacks with Sanji as it's
just variation of kick high kick spin
kick or whatever but a notable mention
is of course Diablo jambe and eventually
Ifrit chambe these see Sanji igniting
his leg increasing his speed and power
and burning opponents on contact and
finally we gotta talk about observation
hockey as Sanji specializes in it this
was framed specifically because he
needed to be constantly Vigilant on the
kalabaka kingdom Sanji is now able to
sense other people's presence strength
emotion and even intention we see him
dodging katakuri's attacks despite
category being a stronger observation
user and he was also able to understand
both Viola and kinemon's true intentions
right off the bat although he was
admittedly blinded by puddin's acting
Sanji senses to shiggy being beaten by
Virgo despite the vast range between
them and even as recent as a few
chapters ago he is the one who sensed
Bonnie when she was trapped in the warm
Eddie between his observation hockey
armament and his genetic enhancements
Sanji is just kind of this perfect
defensive combatant while still being a
threat in his own right which is why I'm
putting him in third place second
obviously goes to Zoro Zorro was the
first crewmate that Luffy picked up way
back in shellstown and he trained in
shimotsuki Village Under koshiro and
made a promise to his rival kawina that
one day one of them would become the
greatest swordsman in the world before
she inevitably passed away by the time
Luffy found him Zorro had earned the
title of pirate Hunter being famous
across the East blue for bounty hunting
it was at this point where even
crocodiles Baroque Works took an
interest in him and sent someone to try
and recruit him Zorro uses three sword
style a method of swordplay which
focuses on one sword in each hand and
one in his mouth and as early as
Alabaster we even see him being able to
slice through steel demonstrating
himself to be devastatingly powerful
very early on like I mentioned in the
Sanji section Zorro also has superhuman
endurance from being nearly cut in half
to mihawk and then immediately fighting
arlong and Hachi to his famous nothing
happened moment to every other battle
where Zorro starts the fight on death's
door only to persevere through it Zorro
is next to Unstoppable once he starts a
fight he will undoubtedly take a load of
damage probably more than anyone else
could but he will get back up and
continue to fight until he finds a way
to win now despite focusing on his
famous three sword style through the
years we've seen Zoro improvise with no
sword style one sword style two sword
style nine sword style and even once
fought with usof chained his arm holding
another sword so he can make the best of
whatever materials he has available and
while we rarely see him fighting without
his sword the dude is monstrously strong
we see him crushing Miss Monday's head
way back in whiskey Peak using just his
hand and of course I always think back
to Thriller bark when we see him lifting
those insane weights while doing a
handstand and that is before his time
skip power boost hell even earlier in
the series during his fight with Mr one
he picks up a collapsing building while
he himself is extremely injured so it's
pretty clear that the dude is fairly
strong so even without his swords I'm
sure he could beat the hell out of
someone but of course we do have to talk
about his actual swordsmanship in terms
of the power of His slices we've seen
Zoro cut through mountains as he fought
Pika he can slice through pacifistas and
now he can even cut combatants like both
King and kaido and a big part of that is
his most recent Evolution after swapping
his shisely for enma enma is a crazy
person's sword swallowing and pulling
out the hockey of its wielder until
there's nothing left the first time we
see Zorro holding it the sword
completely shrivels up his arm and even
accidentally causes him to cut a cliff
in half once mastered though Zoro was
able to use king of Hell three sword
style his currently most powerful stance
which has enma draining all of his
hockey and then infusing that energy
into all three of his swords this gives
him a lot more range and power than ever
before even allowing him to cut and
overpower King despite not being able to
leave a scratch on him before this
started I'd say it's about as
significant a boost as sanji's
enhancements but while sanji's new form
is always active and extremely safe this
seems to be more of a glass Cannon All
or Nothing Last Resort technique so I'm
assuming it's much stronger than sanji's
form but with a much bigger risk
associated with it regardless both are
pretty badass his two sword style tends
to be used when Zorro needs specific
bursts of power and speed like when he's
trying to cut the C train a lot of the
time this form uses more unsheathing and
re-sheathing based attacks like rashimon
or his flying slashes although normal
sword fighting is obviously on the table
as well in this form he's even able to
take on kyuki Maru one of wano's
strongest ninjas with relative ease one
sword style is probably on the lower end
of zoro's power but it's still pretty
impressive his first Panda hole was used
in one sword style he cut through Mr
one's steel he took down ryuma he
overpowered hodi using one sword style
it seems to be that a lot of moments
where zoro's growth needs to happen
immediately or positions where he's put
in a corner and needs to adapt are all
revolving around him being in this one
sword style State now no sword style see
Zorro manifesting his attacks around him
in what looks like Aura this is
apparently not hockey instead his
killing intent made into a tangible
thing which is terrifying and this is
kind of seen again as we move on to nine
sword style which falls into this
category as we see Zorro having four
extra arms and two extra faces it is a
solidified illusion in the same way that
no sword style is it's in this form that
he begins to look like the deity Ashura
and kaido even notices for the first
time that Zoro has access to conquerors
hockey speaking of after just Awakening
Khan conquerors hockey he is able to
knock out several low-level Beast
Pirates very shortly after furthermore
he's even able to infuse his blades with
them as he fought King these are fairly
Advanced abilities for someone who just
learned about having conquerors hockey
yes we've seen most conquerors users
kind of activating their abilities in
moments of stress but the active
decision to trigger conquerors hockey
and knock people out tends to be
something that is learned over time on
top of that infusing his blades with
conquerors is sort of similar to the
ryuo technique that Luffy learned in
wano so it seems like Zorro has some
kind of proficiency with conquerors
hockey at least when it comes to
learning abilities however Zorro's
Armament is his bread and butter using
it to hold back the bird Cage's strings
cutting people clad in Armament
themselves and even fueling enma in
battle of course his observation hockey
is pretty decent being able to detect
caribou and ryugu Palace as well as
Batman's attempt to kill suru with an
arrow from a distance outside of this
though the last thing we need to mention
about Zorro is his ability to cut fire
now like kinemon this isn't the most
powerful ability especially in
comparison to all his hockey but it is
noteworthy all the same and finally the
strongest Straw Hat to no one's surprise
after leaving wano is of course Monkey D
Luffy as a child Luffy ate the gum gum
fruit turning his body into Rubber and
making him resistant to any and all
blunt force attacks that don't involve
hockey this means punches Falls and even
bullets will literally bounce right off
of him it also makes him completely
immune to Electric attacks as well while
originally not being very talented with
his fruit he trained for a decade to
master a variety of long-ranged and
stretchy attacks to the point where his
journey begins with him knocking out the
king of the coast Luffy's biggest
strength though has always been his
imagination and combat sense he's able
to use his rubbery body to find
Solutions in any situation that he finds
himself in and to overcome them or at
least to learn learn from his opponent
to become all that much stronger for
example in his battle with crocodile he
realizes that water is the key to
defeating the warlord so he creates the
water Luffy form and later simplifies it
by using his own blood to harden
crocodile sand and make him vulnerable
it is quick and ingenuitive thinking
similarly cp9 bodied him in water 7 due
to their rokushiki techniques
specifically their speed which allowed
them to overwhelm him and make use of
their powerful attacks to defeat him so
Luffy creates gear second and third gear
second integrates Luffy's imitation of
the shave technique pumping his blood
through his body much faster and
essentially fueling himself into extreme
speeds that bluno just isn't able to
keep up with and by moving at these
speeds his attacks also become strong
enough to overpower bluno's iron body
however Luffy realizes that this ability
strains him and puts him on a clock so
he also created gear third a form which
sees him blowing into his arm terms and
inflating parts of his body for massive
finishing attacks when there's no other
option on top of that we see Luffy
making things like Nets flying saucers
creating boxing gloves out of Mr three's
wax wearing an afro using a golden ball
as a power boost to his gum gum rifle
eating a bunch of crackers and so many
more things that signify his ability to
think on his feet his next big power
boost though would come after learning
and mastering hockey conqueror's hockey
would help him overcome the Marines at
Marine Ford help him defeat the boa
sisters and take out hordes of hody
Jones's men Armament was added to his
gear second and third to make them
immensely powerful and observation would
eventually be trained to the point
fighting katakuri to allow him to see a
few moments into the future and predict
his opponent's actions it's also around
this time that we start seeing that
imagination seems to play a big role in
Luffy's Powers gear second and third
already kind of go beyond the idea of
what rubber should be allowed to do or
at least they stretch the idea to its
logical limits but suddenly we have
attacks like red hawk and Thor elephant
gun incorporating fire and electricity
into his attacks respectively and this
goes even further as we see him enter
gear 4. against Dopey Luffy uses bounce
man a thick bouncy boy who uses elastic
compression rather than the usual
stretch and release that we've seen up
till now this form also allows Luffy's
attacks to look like cannons firing from
his fists and can be multiplied in his
Kong organ attack on top of this Luffy
can grow these to be massive with King
Kong attack and he can even fly with a
motion similar to sanji's Skywalk by
using his compressions and releases to
propel himself which again that is a lot
for rubber to do gear 4 also has Tank
Man a fat form covered in Armament
hockey almost similar to Virgo it makes
Luffy impervious to attacks and allows
him to keep eating to the point where
cracker couldn't make any more soldiers
that's it that's all this form does it's
kind of a meme but I do have to mention
it every time we go through Luffy's
Powers because it's technically there
less of meme though is the final gear 4
version snake man first seen his fight
against katakuri Luffy trades all of his
defensive Armament for offensive stats
making him a glass cannon in this form
his punches can extend endlessly and
will continue to pick up speed and
velocity as they fly through the air on
top of that they can freely change
direction and continue to pick up power
until they hit their target these kind
of form a versatile triangle for Luffy
bounce man for power Snake Man For Speed
and Tank Man when it's dinner time these
forums are further enhanced in wano when
Luffy learns a new form of hockey
expression with ryuo with this Luffy can
Infuse his attacks with conquerors haki
to increase their power as well as to
admit his attacks so that they don't
even need to make direct contact or so
that they can make deeper hits a tool
which is instrumental in his taking down
of kaido whose body was essentially
invulnerable to damage now with all of
this Lu goofy would be just about even
in my opinion with Sanji and zoro's new
powers but of course it doesn't end here
during his fight with kaido Luffy
awakens gear fifth becoming the
embodiment of Joy boy and breaking the
laws of physics as he Embraces Tune
Force it turns out the gum gum fruit was
actually the mythical Nika fruit and
once awakened it allows the user to turn
their imagination into reality which has
kind of been Luffy's whole thing the
whole time in this form Luffy gets this
dope new white color palette a new
outfit and he can do whatever he wants
he's not all-powerful in terms of
strength it's not like we see him one
shot in kaido but his options become
next to infinite we see him getting hit
by a kaido's club only to take the shape
of it and not really take much damage he
bends the ground and turns it into
rubber so he can bounce back Boro breath
he uses kaido as a jump rope he becomes
gigantic and can grab hold of lightning
basically he is not limited by anything
except his creativity this doesn't mean
he's Immortal this doesn't mean he's
Unstoppable and it does seem to drain
him quite a lot but while it's active he
is an insane force of Nature and I think
it's hard to debate about him being the
strongest straw hat but there you have
it all 10 Straw Hat ranked on their
power yes there's some wiggle room and
you could move people from here or there
depending on your interpretation but I
think in general this is a pretty close
to correct list at the very least let me
know if you think I'm crazy or if you
agree with me down in the comments and
if you have some idea for future upon
one piece videos like this let me know
those as well as always if you enjoy
this video remember to leave a like and
you can of course subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss more great
one-piece content in the future finally
feel free to check out my own channel
axle beats if you're interested in
supporting me directly as well but with
that all being said thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time I
hope you all stay excellent